c'est une image qui a fait le tour du
web à l'issue des résultats du second
tour le réalisateur xavier beauvois qui
pousse sa carte d'électeur mécontent de
ne pas voir jean luc mélenchon au second
tour battant de justice mais l'info
instant ça m'intéresse plus un geste
symbolique qui ont navigué certains
alors qu'en france le droit de vote est
une chance le porte-parole gabriel est à
la d'ailleurs réagi à cette polémique on
a quand même une chance en france c'est
de vivre en démocratie et si xavier
beauvois change la ville pourra toujours
aller voter grâce à sa carte d'identité
alors tollé après la réaction du
réalisateur xavier beauvois qui a brûlé
sa carte d'électeur est il allé trop
loin j'ai l'audience allait alors oui
oui non non non non non guillaume non
mais c'est un geste symbolique il a
droit le faire évidemment ça choque ce
que ça doit choquer mais je joue à bord
il ya plein de gens fait qu'ils sont
très mécontents du résultat de ce
premier tour il a droit de le faire et
je pense que c'est un geste très
symbolique qui parle à beaucoup de gens
donc l'impact pourquoi ça choque y a
rien de choquant là dedans bonsoir je
trouve que c'est un geste de capricieux
d'enfants gâtés qui ne verra rien c'est
juste une sorte de posture parce que
déjà même si t'as pas de carte
d'électeur tu peux aller voter une petit
densité tu vois mais ces deux symboles
c'est ça moi je comprends qu'il soit
déçu je comprends sa frustration
effectivement entre 3 et 2 il ya 421
milles et cars 2
deux voies mais voilà mais moi je trouve
que c'est juste une posture et ça sert à
rien au final en fait parce qu'en fait
c'est antidémocratique ce qui dit en
gros en fait je suis pas d'accord avec
les résultats d'élections donc je brûle
et donc je condamne tous ceux qui sont
qui sont pas d'accord avec moi alors oui
c'est trop facile c'est quelqu'un qui
pousse formé à sa canette de signal à
profiter des installations de l'état
français la villa médicis à rome qui a
coûté une blinde et là il vient se
plaint comme si
tout s'était plaint quoi ce type là et
va en profiter quel rapport entre ça et
que le fait qu'il y
ait la démocratie vraiment est jamais
produit
c'est symbolique qui fait ce qu'il veut
c'est pas interdit par la loi il a brûlé
le top 5 des décès s'est targué un
exemple je faisais pas où là encore la
villa médicis que je m'emballe
j'aime bien continuer comme ça oui on
balaye de quoi casse toi à voile a été
de tête exemple nul bah ouais gros
dimaga son ferry mais il a raison il
faut
retenir je retire jeu
très gentiment comme disait voilà
l'infection
c'est la cour d'école ils sont
déjà une émission elle lève la main et
elle parle en même temps non mais non
c'est lui qui va retourner sur touche
pas à mon sport
alors oui de leur mauvais
regard déboires ces gens parole ces gens
s'inspirent en permanence quand ils ne
sont pas contents nous font leurs
petites menaces j'irai vivre à manhattan
je quitte la france je fais ça je pars
si c'est pas comme moi et machin mais
barré vous si vous avez un compte en y
avait une élection les français ont voté
soit vous restez soit vous fermez vos
gueules mais c'était quand même son
petit côté je pars ce plan-là je passe
mon temps à faire des symboles voilà
mais les gens voter il a fait un très
beau score pas celui qui voulait mais ça
suffit maintenant ces gens qui donnent
des sons une jeune noah à l'époque si
chez lui qui passe je pars vivre à
manhattan pour une chance à résister
voilà il est toujours à paris donc voilà
il ya un moment faut arrêter pour
respecter la démocratie et les petites
menaces des people et des gens qui
veulent faire du buzz ça suffit
non non moi je trouve qu'il a avril à
tort de faire ça parce que je sais vrai
vas tu as raison on va voter c'est une
démocratie on a la chance de pouvoir
voter on a la chance d'être en france
monsieur il profite aussi du système des
aides de l'état pour le cinéma parce que
l'état donne aussi pour le cinéma et moi
j'ai toujours un problème avec les
institutions on respecte les
institutions pour moi c'est comme s'il
avait brûlé un billet de banque à partir
donc à marquer république française et
qui à la marianne tu brûles pas des
trucs comme ça moi aussi j'ai envie de
brûler ma déclaration d'impôts
on fait pas
ouais avec liberté égalité fraternité
alors on vous entendez pas ma chérie on
vous entend pas ma chérie metz alors on
peut donner un micro un micro pour la
jeune fille vous plaît comme ça on sait
que voilà
qui vient du mondial de la coiffure
c'est presque pas de ça chez vous mais
moi ma chérie qu'est ce qui se passe et
a déchiré sa carte en fait réfléchir et
ma carte j'ai déchiré ma carte là des
lecteurs mais en vérité je vais te dire
la vérité j'en ai trois des cinq partis
on est trois déclare c'est bon là on
entend c'est le ses leçons cathédrale ok
pas de problème
vient de déchirer ma carte parce que tu
sais quoi là moi je suis énervé par quoi
à ces élections pourquoi des mois
pourquoi voilà c'est son prénom déjà
c'est quoi donc moi je m'appelle à y
soit allé seul voulait tout matagot jean
t'asseoir
s'inquiète pas ici
mais
alors comment tu t'appelles marché noir
alors à part cette boîte est énervé
parce que parce qu'il est mais c'est
intéressant de voir à ce que on a on a
personne qui a vu que tu as eu cette
réaction autour de la placer donc par
action limite elle est intéressante dis
moi pourquoi moi j'suis pas réalisatrice
de cinéma où
tout le monde et feront des tournées
dans tout le monde a son mot à dire donc
fait miroiter énervé moi je suis énervé
se vêtir pas voter qu'ils pêchent dans
les coins ronds non je suis pas client
et jean luc mélenchon je t'avoue
vraiment je savais pas pour qui voter
j'ai voté blanc je te dis l'abattant
hockey très bon voilà quoi t'énerver
alors parce que je suis énervé parce que
en fait je vais t'expliquer un truc moi
j'ai écrit à plein de personnalités
politiques j'ai écrit un hidalgo
[Musique]
puissent être prises lycée ont volé un
devis de travaux à la ferme où je vais
voir attention le placoplâtre à 4,95 à
ça va quoi au baba pour aller vite pour
être témoin pour moi que je te prennent
tout ton temps j'ai fait moi si tu as
bien remarqué je suis une personne en
situation de handicap quand tu vois ça
fait 14 ans que je réclame mon droit à
l'accessibilité par un logement sûr pas
raison ça fait quatre ans j'ai fait
plusieurs procédures judiciaires par
rapport à ça et tu vois on va pas
avancer enfin quand tu sais rien j'ai
écrit au maquereau j'ai écrit trois fois
macron il m'a répondu une fois pour me
dire qu'il a bien reçu ma lettre tout le
bordel moi j'ai écrit à brigitte mâcon
pareil je me suis dit bon peut-être ça
va marcher rien du tout j'ai créé afin
personnalités politiques tu vois
concernant les lois sur l'accessibilité
du handicap en 2005 il ya une loi pour
rendre accessibles tous les transports
en commun tout à fait en 2024 déjà ils
l'ont repoussée de deux sympathiques qui
resteront pas là toujours pas été et
après maintenant ils ont repoussé encore
jusqu'à deux mille 2000 à 2020 2021 2022
on sait même pas alors donc très énervé
pour ça non je vais garder pour ça parce
que là moi j'ai pour moi très énervé sur
le résultat des élections parce que je
vais dire parce que y'a rien qui se
passe la gauche elle chiale elle chiale
elle chiale elle est complètement
effondré la gauche comme disait pour
tous les candidats de la gauche pas les
candidats les électeurs de la gauche les
militants de la gauche eh ben ils sont
orphelins parce que tu vois la gauche on
a beau voter pour eux
et est aussi et tout ça parce que des
fois on a besoin d'elle des fois on a
des projets de vie plan mais voilà en
fait je vais tenir là le truc c'est que
aujourd'hui voilà la gauche c'est
possible oui mais c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas de la faute des autres que la
gauche c'est la gauche et au tibet si
c'est de la faute à la gauche c'est le
mec sympa
ça
coûte en tout cas tu es pas il n'était
pas content tu me va très bien quant aux
ententes à hong kong a lancé qu'il
verdez aussi les bras content parce
qu'il est debout
eh bah merci d'abord je te remercie